hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Oh sir the insult
simulator now I tried to start recording
this a little bit ago but I went on
Facebook to get a little like pregame
Roast going on and I asked you guys to
do whatever you could do to roast me and
try to hurt my massive throbbing ego and
unfortunately or fortunately it was so
good that I spent like an hour and 10
minutes just reading you guys as roasts
and they were so good that I had to
dedicate an entire video just to that
but I'm gonna get to the game here but
I'm gonna give you a little sweet taste
of what's yet to come in the future full
roast video because some of these are so
good that I can't let them slide by
without me seeing it I just want to I
want to get a little little little taste
I don't know what's more fake your
shallow personality or the 15 million
fake YouTube accounts you made and use
to subscribe to yourself to try not to
feel ashamed you're not an engineer you
are the thing we think of when we hear
the year 2013 or rar XD and your
popularity has been shrinking since then
the only people watching you are emos
and twelve year olds by the way five
nights at Freddy's isn't cool it never
was oh my pride
I'd slap you but that would be animal
abuse furthermore you look like the type
of guy that will set up ads for a happy
tapioca I got a Google with a happy
tapioca is do I want a Google what a
happy tapiocas oh oh okay to be but
[ __ ] and submerged in pudding well
mark you did become an engineer after
all you engineered a way to make a
living off preteen fangirls with your
crocodile tears videos while they fuel
your enormous ego no wonder you can't
keep an assistant longer than a few
months nobody else can fit in that house
with how big your head has gotten
college dropout creative cop-out poorly
managed professional relationships at
least you can cling to your ego mark
because nobody on this earth can roast
you harder than you've roasted yourself
also you look like the product of
jacksepticeye anally douching a mixture
of hot sake and dr. Jekyll's bow
[ __ ] what you only started doing skits
as intros to make up for how unfunny
your actual content is you do realize
that my skits are my content and I made
them so if they're funny I'm funny the
reason all your relationships fail is
because you narrate the sex and then sob
after baby you should grow a neck beard
and stop showering since you've already
got the white knighting fedora [ __ ]
down to a science
okay I'm gonna take my bruised ego and
limp into the game now well I'll buy
pride that was a good one okay but
there's a so many more if you want to
find him just go to my facebook page
it'll probably one of the recent posts
if not the one that is most recent
there's so many other ones and the full
roast video is coming very soon don't
worry about that but we are going back
into oh sure the insult simulator and
I'm gonna do a [ __ ] tournament bruh I
can take any of your office I've just
been bruised like nobody's business by
my own fans and I'm still standing and
not crying so I believe I can take what
I wish to complain about this parrot I
purchased I already did this one I lost
to go so I guess I can winner it's dead
that's what's wrong with hey wait I'm
doing this now Oh bah blah blah blah oh
your hat belongs in one of these cages
and was born in I'm gonna hold on to
this I'm gonna hold on you ain't got
that bad so I'll continue mine in the
next one why
thinking about it this bloody [ __ ] well
it's your pet shop hmm why would that be
bad my wife supports your pet shop a
belongs to one of these cages and was
born in born in your your it's born in a
muppet born in a muppet and must be fun
at parties almost there hang on I'm
really whining this one up you calm down
ah belongs in one of those cage
and was born in a muppet and must be fun
at parties you commoner water-ski I
nailed you nailed you to the wall the
job supports you country again you're
just saying really nice things I mean it
seems like what people should do your
sense of style is stoned and looks like
a cheap suit your sense of style is
stone-dead and looks like a cheap I
found your weakness mrs. Maggie you
beloved auntie Oh barely a dent your
sister has bad breath and smells of I
need to see my Chi let me think about
this a cream face una look I got lucky
on that one has bad breath and smells of
a cream faced loon it's there why would
she see I don't like a dead parrot I'm
trying to return a dead parrot why would
my mom like a dead parrot
your father doesn't own a color telly
and this still uses Windows Vista
your father doesn't own a color telly
and still uses Windows Vista yeah take
summer van why wanted to be you what I
mean does that mean that I'm so great
that my wife wants to be me no no don't
combo you are not part of Europe and you
are not part of Europe and have a
steaming romp with public glue but a bit
you are not a part of Europe and have a
steaming rump with a public loo take
summer Vance Oh only one more head and
you'll be dead like okay that's just
opinion I'm sorry madam you are dead you
are gone and daddy
gone and dad you're gone and dead you're
dead you're gone and dead you're gone
indeed there we go oh hell yes [ __ ]
pet show oh yes flash in the park and is
an ill nurtured way face you cross-eyed
inbred muck spout take some of that
you're gone your father oh look at you
bring any sense bloody parrot now
alright then
Oh will I have plenty of them in the box
I want a live one or I'll be back to
complain
yes I'll be back the end okay so the
tournament's stupid because I was just
about to do the same thing that I did
before so I'm just gonna do my entire
brain compartment that's a new one I'm
gonna do that one cuz I haven't done it
here well I'm about to roast someone
real good oh he will guarantee this is
my scissors
unite money probably think so but I have
a ticket first course I you don't look
like a finished class to me really well
then your sense of style talks to
strangers and sits next to a plea z'
give me something good a stewed prune
[Music]
your sense of style talks to strangers
and sits next to a stewed prune of you
son oh oh my goodness
I can't believe this your face oh
there's gonna be good
oh this is gonna be real good your face
has worse hair yes you have a beard than
an English Pig dog and some bloody Minj
er whatever the hell that is
ah [ __ ] nothing
your face has worse hair than an English
Pig dog and some bloody Miller Ming er
sorry I'm asthmatic IDs defeated you
seat what does it mean
alrighty then your math teacher is vile
and is worthless I want to try to
continue this one hmm looks like you
seat because you're a brat oh okay and
maybe I should go for the world's
biggest one honey
we're finishing this off Satan is your
father of geez yay I got a double
manager his fire - it is worthless ah
sits next to your mother honey Oh dearie
me
Oh Buddha you never watch starve and oh
you just gave me ammo you never watch
Star Wars and are an ill nurturer
whey-faced and we're burnt like a witch
bum cancer have bum can't have bum
cancer
I didn't work okay never mind then fire
you know blah blah blah bluh bluh better
went on an ill-natured way face and were
burnt like witches why did it is go blah
blah blah blah blah blah where'd it go
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah this conversation I don't
think so oh you're defeated by this
conversation oh [ __ ]
I know your weakness your sister is
worthless and is deceased
your sister is worthless and dad I'm
that's quite rude but pardon my french
I'm trying to make myself to lose
licenses and is deceased
pardon my friend ha ha ha dad
other stoked you seat well maybe you did
so get the [ __ ] out class myself I just
wanted to see how it felt and it
certainly was worth it uh hard I won't
sit where your filthy bottom was nice
everything worked out in the end I'll
just go on my merry way and not bother
with any of this I think I think that's
a lesson to be learned here have we
gotten any more we got any more levels
have we unlocked anything no no not no
we haven't
how do we all the way unlock it we
unlock what oh Jesus I guess we have to
do the tournament that's what we have to
do right and salt a human oh you can
insult anybody ok let's do this why not
dialing up on the Internet hello who
wants to argue with the bomb bomb
anybody
oh hello oh hello your father is very
naughty and was in jail oh he got an and
see if I got anything your father is
very naughty and was in jail and I have
proof ha ha [ __ ]
your son acts like a dead parrot and
doesn't like your beloved auntie that's
really serious Sam there al scribbles
your father is lyrical and was in jail
and I have proof ma'am I did more damage
take some of that don't take your father
died he took your father course he took
your father that's what he likes to do
your math teacher and your sister
admire pictures a hamster your math
teacher and your sister in my pictures
of a hamster you commoner your math
teacher and your sister pictures old
faster you fool let's get your father
has only local multiplayer and want it
to be your
oh no he knew my weakness damn it why
don't I know your weakness I don't have
your character dammit
alright fine your father is rude and
changes into a hamster damn it I'm gonna
lose this one aren't I
he knows my weakness looks like this
parrot and is rather plain and I'm
serious
ah [ __ ] you Oh father is rude and
changes into a hamster hey I got double
hamster hell yeah
I didn't even know about that take some
of that let's see okay your this
conversation farts in your general
direction ah I'm gonna hold off I'm
gonna build a better one next time how
long as I don't die on this one which I
don't think I will
your husband belongs in one of those
cages I bet I bought wall you were gonna
get you next time
wha but a whale on you would have wheel
on you see this conversation farce in
your general direction and well there's
no and with this new and the [ __ ] the
FAC oh come on there was nothing there
there was nothing I could do [ __ ] it's
nothing
ah [ __ ] huh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I couldn't
we couldn't draw this [ __ ] [ __ ]
her father was an alien hamburger that's
kind of cool actually
this happy about Fox in your general
direction I got screwed are clearly not
a parent expert I can assure you oh oh
you don't you don't even get oh you're
in Earl oh hey your interlocutor ran
away I'm assuming that that means I am
the winner
ha ha ha ha even though it says defeat
up there all right so I lost my first
multiplayer match because I got screwed
over and that's
I ain't knowing no other reason there so
anyway that is OSHA the insult simulator
hope you enjoyed that I shamed myself on
the Internet but I shall win again and
also I wanted to mention I am not
offended by any roasts in any way I can
take pretty much anything you guys can
dish out or anyone here can dish out I'm
actually kind of happy about it it's
weird to be insulted and be like oh it's
so sweet it's a bizarre feeling but you
know you know it has to come from a
place of love before it can come from a
place of hate
so either way thank you everybody so
much for watching I really am tickled by
the response to this because some of
them are so ridiculously creative that
they just make me laugh and others just
big me cried but soon as the cameras
over but a grab a big bear without
here's be the way thank you everybody so
much for watching and thank you
everybody so much for contributing hope
to hope you guys enjoy the full roast
that's gonna come later so thanks again
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
[Music]
you
[Music]